teóricamente el gobierno de pedro
castillo paso superior a fue a prueba de
fuego ante el parlamento y esto es lo
que se señala porque según lo mencionan
algunos seis congresistas lo que ha
hecho el parlamento actual es brindarle
la confianza al presidente pedro
castillo para evitar que éste cierre el
parlamento porque de acuerdo a la
constitución peruana cuando el
legislativo niega al dos veces el
respaldo político al gobierno este
presidente de ejercicio tiene la
facultad de disolverlo es por eso que se
le otorgó el voto de confianza pero esto
no significa que habrá una buenas
relaciones entre el congreso y el
presidente de pedro casi o porque ya se
están programando unas sesiones de
interpelación a los ministros del primer
ministro pedro guido bellido y también
se mencionan que van a realizar mociones
de censura y destitución a los ministros
por lo pronto muchos parlamentarios han
dado a conocer que no están de acuerdo
con los ministros tal es el caso
esfuerzo popular partido político de
keiko fujimori que hacen y que sea
respaldado quizás al gabinete es más
mediocre en la historia y ellos van a
hacer un muro que de contención ante las
gestiones de pedro casi o por lo pronto
el gobernante ha agradecido al
parlamento por esta sesión que señala
que va a permitir la gobernabilidad en
su gestión